[Música]
[Aplausos]
muito boa noite antónio todos feitas as
apresentações
quero falar do tema com traz é que traz
aqui
inicia se por cidadania e cidadania não
é mais do que uma construção social
ativa em que cidadãos têm direitos e
deveres responsabilidades e obrigações
ea cidadania foi nos trazendo e dá ao
mundo pelos três grécia antiga onde o
conceito de cidadania estia existia
dentro e cia para os cidadãos
mas eram os irmãos que era uma minoria
da oposição eram mas com mais 21 anos a
tendência ou filhos no país a aliansce
que pagavam um tremendo imposto
o comerciante ea mulher escravos
estrangeiros não eram cidadãos e
portanto esta questão de cidadania
daquelas que participavam de assinar a
legislação que se viam sociedade era
reservada é uma minoria da população
é certo que vários ex o verão
acha que se passaram e ovo fato é tem
esse direito se não foram foram cortados
com as marcas obtidas com algumas
ditaduras facto um acontecimento que é a
revolução francesa que com 11 e 15 anos
vive as ministras de liberdade igualdade
e fraternidade conseguiu implementar uma
constante na constituição estamos no
final do século 18 em que usar o direito
do voto e isso daí participação plena e
de sufrágio universal e directo aos
cidadãos mas esse mas apenas aos homens
esta e portanto ainda que gosta de ouvir
outras misses títulos na história
francesa é verdade é que temos uma
democracia nós temos uma democracia em
que completa em que as mulheres não
podem votar e por isso quando temos uma
democracia em que estava ser cantada da
posição não pode participar do direito
de voto não temos uma democracia com um
ar muito e mais tarde e aí o primeiro
país
a permitir o reitor votos - foi nova
zelândia em 1893
a frança por exemplo como pena como
exemplo a manhã parecia só consegue
fazer após o final do mundial estamos a
falar em 1935 em portugal só depois do
25 de abril 74 mas foi você que imagem
de que a minoria turismo foi a primeira
mulher a votar em portugal em 1911
isso bate certo temporal - utilizado era
américa era uma nação destruída e
aproveitou um buraco já o dizia que em
portugal só podiam votar
o chefe de família em 1911 1911 são o
carro chefe de família e ela usa essa
ligação
ganhei eu ganhei um conjunto de recursos
aos tribunais ea primeira mulher a votar
primeira e única voltar antes da data
anunciada isto porque em 1903 a primeira
república o veto alterá-la e qualifica
facto conhecer aos movimentos sexo
masculino para dizer e trazê los aqui a
palavra política e política comprar
novamente os gregos não é mais do que a
participação da pólis a participação e
ar de governar a cidade e isso é o que
nós fazemos no nosso dia-a-dia
participação na cidade a participação da
nossa vivência participação naquilo que
fazemos é que fazemos no nosso dia a dia
nos exemplos mais banais quando
reivindicamos em conjunto por minhas
condições do nosso vai na nossa rua
quando pensamos que teremos um parque
infantil um jardim e um parque um parque
o florestal quando exigimos melhorias na
sinalização melhorias na iluminação na
nossa rua do rosário rua o nosso bairro
estamos a fazer por isso que estamos a
fazer política quando assinamos ou
assinava estamos a fazer política quando
escrevemos uma carta é um responsável
governamental estamos a fazer política
quando nos associamos alguém reivindicar
alguma coisa isto acontece nosso dia a
dia e também pequenos exemplos como
quando vamos nos perguntar bouet é que
tá aqui pra fazer política não será
escolher entre maçãs e peras mas tem
quando decidimos por exemplo comprar
umas a portuguesa em vez de uma
estrangeira ou até não iremos nos
perguntaremos um minimercado e aí
fazemos política fazemos
vamos decisões só dois têm consequências
naturalmente em diferentes escalas como
podem perceber isso traz um estudo a
palavra participar
nós todos os dias no que fazemos seja
maior na escala participamos
nós participamos e essa participação não
tem que ver só um conselho no início com
os mecanismos formais
é óbvio que sou importante um crime
formal de votar organismo formal do
participar de uma assembléia
o mecanismo formal de conhecer algumas
das questões mais delicadas lei e que
possam ser aplicadas nós participamos e
participamos muito civicamente quando
podemos temos uma idéia teremos que
vender uma ideia e criamos uma sessão ou
uma organização para fazer 300 animais
para uma está um defesa dos mais
necessitados para promover o questões do
voluntariado quando participamos numa
seleção de estudantes numa organização
acadêmica no grupo desportivo no grupo
dos criativos são e as viagens exemplos
daquilo que é a nossa participação
participação onde fazemos política de
preço não podemos desmobilizar a palavra
política pública não está longe pleito
que não está inacessível a política está
conosco o nosso de areia e por isso não
nos podemos permitir participar nem
podemos dar aos outros
o poder fizeram dar uma minoria poder
precisam querer se exatamente o que
acontecia na grécia antiga quando apenas
uma parte da posição militar oposição
ele decidir por aquilo que era de todos
isto deixa aqui também que eu sou jovem
que deixa também uma mensagem para
jovens ainda e gosto foi tema questão do
regresso ou não do serviço militar
obrigatório é um dos temas onde os
jovens projovem a minha vida sabe que é
infantil para baixo não é ea mostrar um
pouco mais pronunciaram se elas algumas
estruturas talvez algumas muitos
partidários quem tentaram acabar com a
questão mas isto é uma questão que me
afeta a mim e que nos afeta nós
principalmente aos jovens
podemos falar por exemplo da questão
quando discutimos a união européia e
integração portuguesa europeia podemos
podemos o primeiro painel prefeita tem
feito tem virtudes mas uma coisa é
inegável é que deus temos um europeia
temos passos na europa temos paz no
mundo e portanto uma das coisas que eu
gosto de fazer
quando participo é não ter que passar
por determinadas presenças para saber
quem não gostar delas e portanto eu não
gosto da guerra eu prefiro viver em
período passo e isso é um e não preciso
de fomentar a guerra para saber que não
há terra e por isso mesmo eu sou
partidário sou anti guerra atualmente
favorável com a paz tem de ajudar em
todos muitas vezes a maioria silenciosa
que não participa que não se explicam
tem exprimir no sentido de defender que
o que é o nosso modo de vida é aquilo em
que o fato em que acreditamos e por isso
precisamos de ser uma voz coletiva uma
voz que disse que ela teria feito a
diferença porque este não busco voz
mostra aqui e todos já ouviram falar do
vec saída do reino unido na união
européia
o orçamento foi aprovada enfrento temos
aqui a divisão por faixas etárias desde
os mais novos aos mais velhos onde as
batas amarelas significa uns querem
ficar e percebem que a medida que vamos
avançando nas faixas etárias
a maior percentagem de votantes no ceir
e curioso como os mais jovens e os que
vão mais tempo viver como conseqüência
dessa decisão são aqui uns são os que
menos peso que tem na decisão que é
tomada aqui é esquecida em favor da
saída da saída do reino unido da
européia são aqueles que menos têm que
conviver com essa decisão está uma forma
nua e crua porquê porque os jovens que
hoje estão mais aliados e mais afastadas
da participação vivem num contexto
europeu onde já muito fizeram erasmus
mundus percebem o que é viver numa
europa sem fronteiras o que é viver sem
poder viajar sem fronteiras o que
poderia viver e e e passar pela europa e
passar para o mundo saem em conjunto
limitações que existiam à data e por
isso acreditam e provavelmente se fossem
mais participar sem mais ter feito a
diferença nesta está a passar em
portugal em portugal
isto é a taxa de abstenção nos falando
dos mecanismos de participação formal do
voto está em taxa de abstenção que temos
temos nas eleições à presidência da
república 51 3%
se virmos nas últimas legislativas mas a
assembleia da república temos 44 por
cento de abstenção
isso só vamos dar atenção de ambos os
motiva agosto num gráfico desde 1975 e
devemos fazer qualquer outro tipo de
eleição em portugal estão buscava não
pára de crescer press
até quando porque o fato se no início
comecei por dizer
um parece que não há uma democracia
plenamente cumprida quando por exemplo
as mulheres não têm direito a voto que
significavam sensivelmente oitava
posição será que temos uma democracia
está a cumprir o planejamento quando
temos escutado da posição que hoje não é
por questões legais
já o fazer já para lutar nós temos
juntava posição não vota
isso é um facto uma coisa que tem que
pensar nisso tudo que tem que ensinar
porque é uma questão pra mim que é
fundamental que é nós conseguimos
reduzir induzir e e terceiro da educação
podemos induzir as mudanças que queremos
ver no mundo e quero ajudar aqui um
exemplo que me é muito próximo porque
meu ver exatamente com esta ensinar 18
anos em 2009
em 2009 foi a primeira é a primeira
primeiro ato eleitoral formal em que o
público participante sensivelmente um
mês depois de fazer anos e para que os
conhecem o percurso foi que também
anunciava no parque do sabiá tudo o que
havia para saber se que na altura
suficiente portuguesa e matemática e
biologia física química e por ela em mas
aqui não sabia nada tinha
fazia 38 anos podia votar numas eleições
que não sabia por que estava votado em
que estava a voltar
quem é que 100 que essas pessoas faziam
quem eram
isto prova os prazos dizer e projetar
como exemplo o facto falta-nos cumprir
algo que penso no sistema educativo
falta-nos cumprir algo em termos de
ensinar cidadania por um produto de
promover é que esses jovens que formamos
e por todos nós e todos nós passamos
faltamos promover alguma coisa lhes
ensinar a viver em sociedade e esta é
uma imagem icônica ficado pude usar
várias vezes o aluno pergunta quem diz o
que são os impostos como funcionam e
como é que os padres ou podia perguntar
que a assembleia da república o que são
deputados que falam apresenta câmera e
fazem o presidente da república eo
sistema educativo respondendo perguntas
não preocupe muito quando eles são
responsáveis pela produção de energia
das células e portanto hoje mais de tudo
é fundamental também pegar nesta nesta
geração nas gerações que eu acho que
perdemos tempo perdemos a oportunidade
com gerações de congelação um céu e eu
perdemos a oportunidade também de
ensinar desde nos ensinar a todos a
participarem ensinada viverem se lá
quais é que são as regras também não é
por ser uma banda ainda não é mas quais
são as regras e perceber o que podemos
fazer para chegar a este ponto portanto
cria alguma forma tentar variar porque
vivemos participar
nós devemos participar devemos envolver
e com isso ganhar mais conhecimento mais
aprendizagem solucionar mais
aprendizagem sobre o mundo perceber como
é que trazemos conosco e com os outros
para podermos seguir melhor que nos
mesmo quem não os mesmo que nos diz o
que nos jornais como é que verificamos
essa informação
onde estão os feitos news onde estão
onde está o facto é velado e com isso e
com esse conhecimento e podemos discutir
criticamente os assuntos perceberam esta
informação perceber quem diz o quê
se vir melhor e esse é o motivo por qual
também estava aqui e esta reflexão
porque eu acho que é dessa forma
e com essa com esse ideal que nós
podemos contribuir para a construção do
futuro porque quando nós participamos
nos envolvemos na construção da nossa
rua do nosso bairro da nossa vila da
nossa cidade do nosso país e do nosso
mundo estamos também contamos a
contribuir para que isto seja tudo
melhor
temos que ser envolver nos mais e que o
fato possamos ter a nossa cidade mas
envolvida e mais alerta com maior nas
sombras
aquilo que queremos dar à cidade e é
também com casa eu acho que mais do que
eu chegar aqui qualquer tipo você não
acho que cada um é o importante neste
momento é cada um de vocês consiga
tornar num multiplicador
ou seja muito vocês já o fazem e hoje
não é tudo feito na escola há um papel
fundamental da família dos amigos nesta
convicção nesse convencimento do fato
temos todos que nos envolver
para um país melhor mas principalmente
aproveitar este momento para que todos
nós nos tornemos multiplicadores e que o
facto quando tivermos que quando
tivermos de participar fato possamos
criar a diferença e contribuir para um
país melhor para uma gestão melhor
legislação
certamente vencerá os mais novos também
estamos todos para construir um futuro
melhor
[Aplausos]